ah
[Música]
bueno aprender matemáticas antes sin
usar tecnología era un poco más
complicado y un poco más complejo para
algunas personas realmente a mí antes de
usar tecnología para aprender
matemáticas
también me gustaba y todo eso pero ahora
con la implementación de la tecnología
entonces es como que da una motivación
adicional al aprendizaje en matemáticas
y realmente me gusta mucho más realmente
hay una gran ventaja de estudiar con
tecnología ya que puedes avanzar según
el proceso de aprendizaje que tú tengas
según la capacidad que puedas tener y
sobre todo pues este este reinvertir esa
información otra vez porque si no
entendiste algo esa esa información se
encuentra ahí y tú la pueden volver a
ampliar la puedes volver a investigar y
pro y de esa manera tú amplía sus
conocimientos en matemáticas y lo haces
mucho más fácil ya que no depende
simplemente de un libro para poder
aprender sino hay mil maneras con el
avance de la tecnología para poder
aprender matemáticas y que se te haga
mucho más fácil la verdad creo que la
parte contentas al reto de dominio o sea
me gusta mucho porque cuando por ejemplo
cuando en él
aunque de casa de ejercicios tú terminas
lo normal o lo diario y ahí te aparece
práctica a 5 veces más si no me equivoco
te ves más para lograr el dominado y
podría la sección de dominio que eso es
lo que cuando te entrabas te dan como un
examen general de todo lo que había
estado viendo y ahí podías ver podías
ganar más puntos y es que lo hacías todo
bien y si lo hacía todo bien te aparecía
como la unidad terminada entonces era
como una manera de repasar tus
conocimientos previos como un ticket de
entrada por decirlo así y era agradable
porque tú podías ahí ver cuál era tu
nivel de conocimiento de matemática y si
lo llegamos a completar todos apareciese
por ciento completados una sección
entera y ahí viene al particular me
gusta que era lo de coleccionar las
medallas y les quita un poco el miedo y
el estigma de que nadie puede aprender
matemáticas las matemáticas sólo son
para unos no como dicen todos podemos
aprender lo que sea a veces se me
dificulta van algunos problemas pero
siempre me ha gustado resolverlo porque
no me gusta quedarme con
la idea de que no pude resolver un
problema pero ahora se me hace un poco
más fácil ya que tenemos la plataforma
khan academy que nos brinda una
oportunidad para entender mejor las
clases y nos da conocimientos básicos
sobre el curso de matemática y otros más
siento que cuando una persona se rinde
no están logrando todos sus sueños y
cuando uno tiene metas tiene sueños
siempre tiene que buscarlos y nunca
rendirse también me tocó el caso de un
chico con un ejercicio que lo hizo como
100 veces porque le pedía 10
consecutivos correctos y se equivocaba y
volvió empezar y se equivocaba pero
cuando lo logró él dijo maestra esto
jamás se me va a olvidar y yo sé que yo
lo aprendí no yo creo que es esa parte
de la superación personal que de repente
ya no es el reto con los compañeros sino
es el reto con uno mismo para poder
seguir avanzando un poco de nervios ya
que nunca en el colegio bien creado una
aplicación así y no tengo no tenía en
ese entonces un buen manejo de la
tecnología
y el hecho de entrar me causó mucha
emoción porque no sólo trataba de
matemática encontraba temas muy
diferentes a lo que es matemáticas
química física entre otras y me quedé
sumamente asombrada porque yo me quiere
me quería culturizar y me quiero a
seguir culturizando para hacer una
persona de bien que la ventaja que tiene
la plataforma académico es que
los chicos o la edad de los chicos con
los que trabajo son oscilan entre 14 y
16 17 años entonces ellos son muy
adictos a los videojuegos que tiene cada
académico yo les digo muchachos eso es
como un videojuego quieren ganar monedas
quieren ganar tu savatage que ya lo
quieren cambiar lleguen a donde tienen
que llegar desde la oportunidad de
aprender matemáticas jugando esa es la
idea con cada cadena lo que más me gusta
de la plataforma khan academy es los
avatares porque tienes que evolucionar
los sumando puntos y haciendo
actividades y cuando tienes un avatar
que está mucho más evolucionado que otro
que siempre es un poco más feliz porque
has estudiado tasso forzado para lograr
eso si éste hay una competencia sana que
entre mis compañeros porque éste siempre
hay uno que quiere ser mejor que se van
superando y estoy me quiero quedar atrás
que se me quiera superar y también estoy
siendo uno de los primeros y que cuando
yo acabo mis actividades entonces ayuda
a mis compañeros porque hay algunos que
no entienden muy bien los ejercicios
antes
yo voy a ayudarlo les paso un poco de mi
conocimiento y aparte de algunos tienen
todavía el roche de que les puede llamar
la atención entonces de compañero a
compañero nos entre nos entendemos más
lo que más me gusta es que te ayuda a
ser persistente yo me caracterizó por
ser una persona persistente claro que a
veces tengo frustraciones como todo ser
humano pero a mí me gusta seguir
adelante y lo bueno de khan academy es
que no te da tan fácil la respuesta te
ayuda a buscarla de con tus propios
métodos una manera diferente a la que
ellos te brindan y tú aprendes mejor
estimulas mejor tu aprendizaje
y hasta que llegues a la respuesta y
sientes una gran satisfacción de poder
decir oh sí pueden lograrlo en mi caso
cuando yo logra hacer algo me siento
feliz ya que esto me va a servir en un
futuro para ser profesional y
enorgullecer a mis padres y ver la
sonrisa de mis padres al ver cada día
que me superó más
es una emoción tan satisfactoria y
satisfactoria que te alegra el corazón y
te da ganas de seguir adelante y luchar
por todo lo que tienes
[Música]
[Risas]